هو بين طبعا مانع المريدي عندما بدا الحكم
ايضا والانتقال لهذه الجهه هناك انجب ابنه
ربيعه ولهذا يخلط بعض المؤرخين انهم
يذكرون مانع بالربيع المريضي وهذا ليس
صحيحا بل المانع هو الجد الاعلى وله ابن
ربيع وربيعه ايضا تسلسل منه عدد من
الابناء الحقيقه بينهم تقريبا الفتره
الحكم يعني من سنه 850 الى في عام 1139
الى فتره الامام محمد بن سعود استمر على
اماره الدرعيه من هذين الفرعين المقرن
والوطبان ايضا الفرع منهم نعم وايضا الجد
الاعلى ابراهيم بن موسى بن ربي مانع
المريدي الذي كان يحمي ايضا هذه المنطقه
وجدت له الوثائق ايضا في الدول الخارجيه
سنه 1981 عندما كان ايضا يحمي هذه المنطقه
فمنذ ذلك التاريخ هذه المرحله من سنه 850
الى عام 1139 استمر ايضا هناك عدد من
افراد هذه الاسره الحاكمه تقريبا العشرين
شخص 20
هو الرقم 21 من حكام الدوله على حسب نظريه
ابن خلدون في الاجيال تعرفها الكل ثلاث
اشخاص من الاباء يعني انت وابي ووالدك
وجدك تشكلوا 100 عام وقد نسبه تقريبيه
تقريبا ولهذا بدات حكم الاسره السعوديه
يعني ليس حكما قريبا انظر الى الفتره
التاريخيه القديمه ربما من اكبر يعني اطول
الاسرات الحاكمه في العالم او في واقعنا
المحلي وايضا الاقليم ولهذا من سنه 850
كما ذكرت الى عام 1239 21 حاكم لهذه
المنطقه الواحد والعشرين هو الامام محمد
بن سعود بن محمد طبعا ليس بالضروره انكم
كلهم من اباء او واجازه بس من ابناء عمومه
اجداده بان الجد الاعلى الرابط والجد
الاعلى الذي انتشر من هذه الاسره في جدهم
الاعلى ابراهيم وابراهيم ايضا له السلطه
وله القوه وله الوثيقه ايضا كما ذكرنا
الذي كان يحمي الحجاج وتفرع منه اربعه
افرع رئيسيه